[Music]
you would like to see more male nudity
yes show yes talk about that well it's
okay I'm full disclosure my mom really
troubled me for saying that I know so I
said I know I said in a magazine I said
that there should as a way of talking
about the fact that I think there should
be more you know equal nudity as a way
of there's a lot of female nudity
there's plenty of female nudity myself
included and I feel like it should I
think it's I think it should be a bit
more of a discussion that's between you
know we get some equal male nudity and
female nudity I think it's good you know
are you talking about just what you
traditionally see is guys butts going by
and pretty much yeah that's what you
normally see a mob um yeah you know Andy
I can't believe you did that
why was it already on the card no no I
that's yeah well you know that's a
discussion that should be had
well I think yeah exactly I think it is
it I think it is a discussion that
should be had but I did I said this in a
magazine and then my mom told me off so
I have to stop talking about it she told
me to Elevation it's so funny because I
like it that you are like my mom still
has control over me she could say well I
didn't like that at all yeah and I go on
okay it won't happen again
pretty much everything I do on
television you have so many titles yeah
you have that's your big card penis yeah
most people's workplaces don't work like
we tried that rule around here
you